hey everyone say with register nurse
Orion comm and in this video I'm going
to be going over an an CLECs review
about chest tubes what I want to do in
this video is I'm going to cover the
things you need to know exactly for the
NCLEX exam I'm going to cover the
anatomy the different types of drainage
systems the purposes and the nursing
interventions whenever you're
maintaining these systems and after you
watch this lecture be sure to go to my
website register nurse Orion comm and
take the free quiz that will test you on
your knowledge about how to take care of
chest tubes and a card should be popping
up so you can access that so let's get
started first let's start out talking
about the purpose of a chest tube what
is it and what does it do okay it is a
tube that is inserted into the pleura
space of the lungs to remove air or
fluid to help re-expand the lung so
let's look at what it does okay we have
our lung here that is that little red
area on the drawing then around the lung
we have a little protective layer called
the visceral pleura and then we have
this small little space and then around
that space that attaches to our thoracic
cavity is called the parotid pleura and
what happens is that whenever you
breathe in and out these two layers
glide gently over each other because in
the pleura space there's a small amount
of serous fluid that allows them to
glide nice and gently to prevent them
from rubbing together but while they're
gliding they're creating a negative
pressure which allows your lungs to work
properly and to inflate and deflate
now whenever something gets into this
space like air or fluid the lungs are
like oh no this is not right it's
messing up our pressure setting because
we have a negative pressure and it
causes the lung to collapse so the
physician will go in there and insert a
chest tube to help drain out that air
and that fluid that's called
this lung issues now there is another
type of chest tube which is um called a
media Steindl chest tube and this is a
tube that is inserted into the
mediastinum space and it's typically
placed under the sternum to drain fluid
from around the heart after cardiac
surgery because a lot of times after
cardiac cardiac surgery there can be
extra blood or fluid and this can get
around the heart and compress it and
send the patient into cardiac tamponade
so those are placed as well now let's
take it a little bit deeper and look at
some other reasons why a chest tube
might be placed okay the first one we
hit on this is a pneumothorax and this
is just where air enters into this small
little space and causes the lungs to
collapse this can happen because of like
trauma or spontaneously happen I've had
patients who've been admitted the doctor
wasn't sure why they had a pneumothorax
it just happened spontaneously another
thing is called a pleura effusion and
there's different types of pleura
fusions depending on what type of fluid
is in that floor space and what it is
it's just fluid in the pleural space so
here's your nice little space and some
fluid gets in there messes up that
pressure setting and the lung collapses
and they have some major breathing
issues
okay different types of pleura fusions
you have hemithorax which is where blood
enters into the pleura space hemo means
blood and this can be due to a trauma
a disease like tuberculosis or a blood
clotting issue they're not clotting so
blood is leaking in there another thing
is called a FEMA where they can get an
infection in the pleura space and a last
type of pleura fusion it's a silo thorax
which is where lymphatic fluid can get
into the pleura space and of course
another reason for a chest tube is the
cardiac surgery now let's look at the
different types of chest tube drainage
systems and whenever you get a job as a
nurse be sure to familiarize yourself
with the different types of chest tube
drainage systems your facility offers
and make sure you get a good end service
on that because different
places have different test tube drainage
systems okay here are your basic ones
I'm going to be going over and for in
CLECs purposes the wet suction and the
dry section and let me go over the basic
setup of how a typical chest strain is
set up and then we'll talk about the
differences between the two okay so you
have your little suction device the tube
will go will be coming from the patient
and this tube right here is from the
patient it's draining down into the
drainage chamber these are your drainage
chamber where whatever is coming out of
that line is flowing down into there
then in the middle you have your water
silk chamber and there's blue water in
this and as the patient breathes in and
breathe out this water will toss will
tape up and down and sometimes there's a
little ball in there that will move as
well and then you have a little montaner
leak monitor area and in this area you
are looking for bubbling because if you
see continuous bubbling which we'll go
over in depth
whenever I'm covering the nursing
interventions and there could be an air
leak and then over here at the very end
you have your suction control chamber
now notice on the wet suction and the
dry suction it looks a little bit
differently and that is the biggest
difference with these two systems is the
suction how the section works so let's
cover it okay wet let's talk about the
wet section okay the West section is
regulated by the height of the water in
the section control chamber when it's
connected to wall sections so whenever
you're setting up a wet section chest
tube drainage you will be filling this
with the water that it comes with and
depending on what the physician orders
you'll fill it up to whatever they order
and typically it's negative twenty
centimeters of water and this right here
once you connect this tube to the wall
section will regulate the suction
control of the chest tube and you will
hear bubbling and see gentle bubbling in
this as it's working so that is normal
now with dry suction the water there is
no water column and the suction is
controlled and uses
suction monitor bellow that balances the
wall suction and you can adjust the wall
suction pressure by using a little
rotary suction dial on the side of the
system so this area right here this is
where your suction monitor bellow is and
it looks like a little orange accordion
area and whenever you turn on the wall
suction to this to this little orange
accordion will start to expand out and
you have this little triangle there that
tells you once it gets to that triangle
its regulating suction it's good and
then here you have your suction control
regulator and you have a little dial on
the side where you can set the
prescribed section of whatever the
physician orders and here it's set on
negative 20 like health it would be over
there in the water suction now with the
drive
suction systems you can get a height you
have higher suction pressure options
there's no bubbling of water because you
don't have a water column like how you
do on wet section and there's no water
evaporation with the wet suction because
you have this water you have to fill it
over time that this can evaporate so
you'll have to monitor that make sure
it's at a good level here you don't have
that so you won't have water evaporation
now let's look at our nursing
interventions of things that you have to
do for this patient who has a chest tube
the biggest thing you want to do
whenever you're taking care of a patient
with a chest tube is you want to monitor
the patient's respiratory status very
closely you want to monitor the drain
system itself and you want to know what
to do when things go wrong like if the
chest tube becomes dislodged
accidentally or the system breaks and
how to assist the physician with
removing the chest tube and I'm going to
be covering all those things so first
let's talk about the drainage system and
the tubing ok the drainage system itself
needs to keep needs to be kept below the
patient's chest and the tubing
especially the tubing coming from the
patient it tends to be long and bulky
and patients roll over on it gets caught
up in a side rail so you want to make
sure that those connections are secured
and that they're draining
down into the system and that there's
nothing no stagnant fluid collecting in
those and clots and that your
connections are still next while you are
taking care of this patient with the
chest tube you're going to be watching
the collection chamber the water sealed
chamber and the suction control chamber
and this is going to tell you a lot
about what's going on with the patient
but first let's talk about the drainage
collection chamber the drainage
collection chamber is whenever you're
monitoring this you want to note the
color of the drainage how much they're
putting out typically less than 100 CCS
per hour and you want to record it very
very well regularly because physicians
are going to ask you how much is that
chest tube putting out next the water
seal chamber this is your water seal
chamber on the dry section and on the
wet wet section what does the water seal
chamber do it performs an underwater
seal to allow air to be removed from the
floor space while preventing outside air
from entering into the lungs because
remember we want to create a negative
pressure in there because that's what
the lungs like so that water seal helps
us do that now one thing you want to
know this is normal the water will
fluctuate in this water seal chamber it
will auscultate up and down so that's
normal you want that and whenever the
patient breathes in if the water height
will increase and when they expire have
expiration decree the water will
decrease however it's the opposite if
the patient is on positive pressure
mechanical ventilation
whenever the vent breathes in for them
the water will decrease when the vent
breathes out for them the water will
increase so just commit that to memory
now NCLEX question what if the water in
the water sealed chamber you notice it's
not fluctuating at all what could be the
issue
well the lung may have re-expanded
corrected or problem or there's a kink
somewhere so you want to check that out
next the air leak monitor area this is
part of the water so chamber and
at the bottom and what we're looking for
and that is bubbling NCLEX loves ask
questions about bubbling so what's the
big thing normally there should be no
bubbling in there because it's
monitoring for air leaks however if you
have excessive bubbling noted in that
area that could mean an air leak however
if the patient has a pneumothorax there
could be intermittent bubbling in this
now let's think back to a pneumothorax
what is a new mouth works remember we
talked about at the beginning of lecture
where air enters in to the pleura space
so as that air as that patient is
recovering air will escape and leak from
the lungs into the water sealed chamber
so you could see a little bit of
intermittent intermittent bubbling so
that could be normal for them but the
excessive continuous bubbling is not
that can indicate an air leak okay
next part of it is the suction control
chamber remember on the wet section we
have the water column and on the dry
section we have the suction bellow a
little regulator that works with that
biggest thing you need to know is that
with wet suction you're going to hear a
continuous bubbling noise and you're
going to see gentle bubbling and this
that is normal because it's connected to
wall section that's telling us it's
working with and the water can evaporate
over time so you want to make sure that
you're adding water if it does evaporate
evaporate to keep it at the prescribed
amount of section with the dry section
there's no water column and it's
regulated by that section monitor bellow
that little orange accordion thing other
thing you want to do is you want to
monitor your patients lung sounds how
fast they're breathing if they're having
any complaints of difficulty breathing
like dyspnea and watch the insertion
side look at it make sure it's free from
infection and also check for any sub-q
crepitus or sub-q emphysema also called
that this is where carbon dioxide
escapes into the tissues and whenever
you feel it will be puffy and you feel
it you'll never forget it if you ever
feel it it feels like a crackling
sensation underneath the skin
also you're going to be having the
patient cloth and deep breathe that
helps move fluid and keeps their lungs
nice and functioning and you're going to
be repositioning them okay what to do if
the chest tube becomes this Lodge this
happens cover the site with a sterile
dressing and tape it on three sides
doing this will allow air to escape and
prevent a tension pneumothorax and
notify the position immediately okay
what happens if this system breaks you
walk into the room it's fell over
cracked you need to get a new one while
you're waiting on your new one to arrive
order a new one you'll take the tubing
and insert it one inch into sterile
water to make that water seal and get a
new system okay what about milking or
stripping the tubing this used to be
done a long time ago however it's not
really recommended anymore and due to
increasing pressure so always follow
your hospital protocols with this
another thing clamping another issue
always follow Hospital protocols what do
they say to do with that and because
there's an increased risk of increase in
the patient's chances of developing and
tension pneumothorax and never do it
without a physician's order okay so
removal of a chest tube typically the
physicians will do this and some
facilities nurses have been checked off
through competencies to do this but
typically for NCLEX purposes you will be
assisting the physician usually done at
the bedside and what you will do is you
will gather the supplies typically
varies on physician preference so always
make sure you know what your physicians
like sterile gloves dressing supplies
and this could be occlusive petroleum
bass Tesla whatever a mask gloves a
suture removal kit and rubber tipped
hemostats okay one thing you're going to
be doing prior prior to removal you're
going to teach the patient how to do
what's called the valsalva maneuver and
this is where you have the patient take
a deep breath exhale and bear down and
they
we'll do this during removal the
reasoning for this is to prevent air
from entering that pleural space during
removal so that helps decrease that from
happening
then if ordered up you'll premedicate
the patient for pain because this can be
painful position the patient in semi
fowlers position and afterwards you're
going to monitor the respiratory status
listen to those lungs sounds watch for
equal chest rise and fall make sure it's
not unequal any drainage is the patient
breathing okay are they complaining it's
hard to breathe and typically after a
removal is done the physician will order
a chest x-ray to assess lung expansion
so that is an Inc let's review about
chest tubes now going to my website
register nurse orange comb and take the
free quiz to test your knowledge and be
sure to check out my other in CLECs
review videos and thank you so much for
watching and please consider subscribing
to this YouTube channel